next we have Cali Bloom and Christopher
Ewing a husband and wife writing team
and their script tape22
it's the story of a grieving music
journalist
who suddenly finds that he can bring his
beloved wife back from the dead with the
help of a magical mixed tape
please join me in welcoming Callie and
Christopher to the stage
thank you
oh two of them
thank you very much okay I think I'll
set my number
hello
um thank you for being here I was told
on the way up not to trip because
Jennifer Lawrence has already done that
so I feel like this is a success already
always comparing you to Jennifer
Lawrence
um and just like Sam we're very excited
to be able to say thank you to the
academy we actually had to fight over
which one of us was going to get to say
that I won um but in all seriousness
thank you so much to the academy and to
everyone on the nickel committee to Joan
and Eric and Chris and Alex and to all
of the readers it's been truly
life-changing already so thank you uh
we're also incredibly lucky to have a
amazing group of talented friends that
give us the most insightful notes and uh
sometimes even hire us to do things
especially Sean Patrick Kelly Colin
Brooker uh Naveen Singh Cherise door of
Christian Cruz and Alex odd and we
wouldn't be the filmmakers we are today
without the mentorship and guidance of a
few people especially Scott bowling and
Tim boxel Julie oxendale Susanna Daniel
women in film and Miguel sapochnik and I
personally would not be the person I am
today without my mom and dad my
incredible mom and dad who raised me in
a house full of love and creativity
where we constantly and always talked
about books and movies and music and art
all the time and thank you to my parents
for being so supportive and not freaking
out when I told them I was leaving my
very steady salaried career with health
care benefits to instead write scripts
about magical mixtapes and dead spouses
so thank you
um and we also would not have been able
to write this particular script without
our daughter uh Marlo who's five and
whose middle name is Sydney after Sydney
Prescott from the scream films which
should tell you everything you need to
know about Cali and I
so Chris and I have spent the last
decade um working in what I like to say
great careers for other people I worked
in healthcare Tech and Chris worked in
content marketing directing and
producing other people's passion
projects and we decided that our
definition of success was really working
together on projects that we were really
passionate about so we saved our money
we wrote A Five-Year Plan based very
Loosely on rizza's Five-Year Plan for
the Wu-Tang Clan uh based out of which
is detailed in the Wu-Tang manual you
should all read it and he's totally not
kidding 100 really did Rizza guides my
life uh and we left our careers and uh
just in time for covid to hit so we took
the quarantine and we tried to make the
best of it by writing the movie that we
most wanted to see in the world and that
was a funny drama about grief ghosts and
great music and the driving engine of
our script tape22 is really this idea
that a song can change the world that a
piece of art can warp reality on a
molecular level
and it seems like after the last couple
years that have been so rough on our
Lawns our democracy our Collective
psyche you know it's a great opportunity
for all kinds of stories to to change
the world
um
by the way Callie told me I could only
get about five percent political tonight
so I have cut everything about all of
the book Banning anti-science
disinformation spreading election
deniers from this
speech Yes I felt that would push it
past five percent
but now to introduce
um our scene from tape 22 Hutch our
protagonist has brought his wife Sam
back from the dead just once for a few
seconds
um he totally freaked out he thought
maybe he had a tumor that was pressing
against the dead wife part of his brain
or he was totally going insane but now
he's able to bring her back for a second
time but they still don't know the rules
or how this magical situation works so
without further Ado thank you so much
yes thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]